hello everybody welcome I'm Marjorie
Schuster with the Stryker Center tonight
we have Jonathan Weissman who is the
congressional editor and deputy
Washington editor at the New York Times
his previous novel is called number four
Imperial Lane and the book was speaking
about tonight is semitism being Jewish
in the age of Trump his long journalism
career has taken him to the Baltimore
Sun the USA Today Washington Post Wall
Street Journal and The New York Times
where he's covered Congress for
presidential campaigns the war in
Afghanistan and the Obama White House
after the event were going to distribute
books and he's graciously agreed to sign
everybody's book so we'll sort of go out
there to the right
he's going to speak on this fascinating
subject and then we're gonna open it up
to the audience so there'll be a lot of
dialogue a lot of Q&A back and forth mr.
Weissman thank you good evening everyone
my name is Jonathan Weissman you
probably know that you bought your
tickets or you came here made your way
after last week's snow date but I say my
name because it has some meaning that I
never really thought about it sounds
Jewish for most of my life I didn't
think very much about that that I had a
Jewish sounding name I grew up in a
moderately Jewish household in Atlanta I
grew up in a very reformed synagogue I
was bar Mitzvahed without the
encumbrance of a Hopf Torah portion I
still messed up the prayer after the
Torah reading I thought it was normal
that my shul had an electric arc that
the door came down and the lights came
on and we also had a Christian choir
that was ensconced behind curtain so it
would sound that much more angelic I
went off to Chicago for college and the
only interaction I ever had with that
with Hillel at Northwestern was an
argument my senior year with the rabbi
for the two-state solution versus the
Canton solution I'm not gonna go over
that right now because as I say in my
book I think Jews in the United States
discuss Israel way too much I did insist
that my children would be raised Jewish
when I married my college girlfriend way
way too young as you might have guessed
she wasn't Jewish she was in fact the
daughter of a lapsed Catholic turned
Pentecostal is my mother-in-law used to
ask me what I would call somebody who
followed all the tenets of my religion
but took Jesus as their Savior and I
said I called him a Christian and that
always disappointed him when my
daughters were born more than 10 years
later I did insist or Abbott Ari when we
were being married I insisted that we
would raise my raise our daughters
Jewish our children Jewish but they were
born like 10 12 years later and my wife
at the time felt like she would feel
like an alien in her own house if she
was the only non Jew there and you know
I didn't hold her to a promise that she
made really as a child so we raised them
nothing no I actually might my daughter
told me that I should mention that
through her own force of will my younger
daughter did insist on a Jewish
education and although she got it a
little belated Lea I will say that it
was not too late I say none of this with
any pride in fact I say it with a little
shame but my point is this I was a
pretty typical Jew of my generation and
that means not particularly Jewish at
all until I was and it was all because
of that name Wiseman in May of 2016
Donald Trump was marauding through the
Republican primaries somehow the
Republican cognoscenti in Washington
thought they were going to stop him from
getting the Republican nomination
through some undetermined deus ex
machina that never and manifest itself
at the time Robert Kagan a Brookings
Institution scholar and a Republican of
Good Standing wrote a column called this
is how fascism comes to Ameri
cup and as I did often I took a snippet
from it I put it on to Twitter and I
sent it out into the world
I got an odd reply back from somebody
who called himself cyber Trump it just
said hello Weissman that's it except the
Weissman was in three parentheses I
didn't know what it meant i intuited
that because Weissman was a Jewish
sounding name it had some kind of
meaning so I said care to explain and he
said came back what-ho the vaunted
Ashkenazi intelligence hahaha I have
it's a dog whistle fool I have bailed
the cat from my fellow [ __ ] and then
the onslaught began and let me explain
what Belling the cat meant I didn't know
this at the time I came to know it later
unbeknownst to me an enterprising member
of the alt-right their name not mine
that strange agglomeration of racists
anti-semites white nationalists in
America firsters had created a piece of
software called a google plugin you
could get it on google it had the brand
name of the coincidence indicator so it
wouldn't rise to google's notice but if
you downloaded the coincidence indicator
you could search for jews to go after
Google searches don't pick up
punctuation marks I don't know if you
knew that I didn't know that but if you
have the coincidence indicator you could
go for one particular set of punch
roommate and punctuation marks with
these three parentheses they called them
echoes by the way a leader of the
alt-right named Andrew Anglin who
happens to be this very malicious editor
of the daily stormer a neo-nazi site had
decided that he would slap these
parentheses on Jewish targets mostly
Jewish journalists at the time and then
his minions could search and destroy so
I was certainly not the only one there
were dozens of Jewish journalists who
were bailed and the results were vicious
I went back to look for some
them recently because I wanted to show
people what they looked like the very
worst ones that were purged by Twitter
but there are plenty out there and I do
want to show you what they looked like
so I probably shouldn't read all of
these or with the through the the house
of worship but they come out right what
right with what it is it puts the gold
star on the chest or it gets the hose
again
this is a one of my friends Darrell
lampshade the charming name quick
question why have the Jews been kicked
out of so many countries if they never
did anything wrong please answer this is
a common theme in the alt-right they
like to make Jews answer to our own
oppression I will just point out that
Ari Goldberg is almost certainly not
this man's real name and he uses this
this is an all trite cartoon character
of the sniffling Jew he actually has a
name there's a hole in my book I
explained the whole origin of that
cartoon character and he shows up again
and again in all trite motifs this is an
image of another journalist Giulia Yaffe
Giulia fee was at that time a she works
for the Atlantic now she was a freelance
journalist she had done a profile of
Melania Trump and she had gone back to
Slovenia where her faint aura on his
family had come from and she wrote what
I think most journalists thought was a
fair and a nice profile but Melania did
not like it and because Melania did not
like it
the the trolls in the in the alt-right
their kind of storm troopers decided to
go after Julia with great vehemence
here's a picture of Julia getting her a
head shot by a Nazi this is a common
motif you put a journalist in a gas
chamber and have Donald Trump throw the
switch I won't let I read all these but
here's another one there's a picture of
of Daniel day-lewis and I'll just tell
you Daniel daily
was not a member of the alt-right he is
at one time he he was in the I don't
know if you all saw Martin Scorsese's
Gangs of New York this epic from the
early 19th century and he played a
nativist character named bill the
butcher and Twitter allows you to to
take on any any identity you want and
bill the butcher just happens to be a
common one in the in the anti-semitic
world and this is another one that I
just bring out because it is another
example of how they make you answer to
your own oppression having Jews been
kicked out of out from All Nations
it will be your turn soon I mentioned
this also because we're all fixated
rightly on the anti-semitism that is
surging in Europe and that's an
anti-semitism born of anti-zionism you
anti-semites in the they come new breed
of anti-semites in France and and and
Britain hate Israel but the all right
doesn't really hate Israel they all
right sees Israel as an F no Neth no
state and they want an ethnos state they
want to whiten or a white nation in what
is now the United States and they see
Israel as a place for us Jews to go to
now and we are not white according to
their views so they're not actually if
they don't really don't really fit in
with the European concept of this new
European concept of anti-semitism this
is another one they actually the thing
is that they love to get a rise from the
people that they're targeting so they
think that's very funny that there's no
business like show business I'll just
let that one speak for itself
Gables it's it's kind of funny because
the Nazis lost World War two but they
they find real heroism in Joseph
Goebbels and any and all things all
things Third Reich so
is a concept that the Jews run
everything in secret and if the [ __ ]
if the non-jews could just discover the
the the secret to how the Jews run
everything then we'll have to shut it
down and this is a thing you hear all
the time in the alt-right the [ __ ]
knows shut it down and as I said the
outright would like us to leave and they
have a place for us to go Israel and
that's Donald they had empowered Donald
Trump to send us away so that is I just
wanted to show you a few things we don't
need these anymore and you know people
often ask me if I was scared during all
of this did I fear for my life did I
worry about my children and perhaps I
was foolish but I didn't I wasn't really
scared I just wasn't going to be
threatened by these two bit cyber
terrorists Nazis but you know I am
scared now because since I began writing
this book about my own experiences a
follower of what he called the old rife
came upon a young black student at the
just outside the University of Maryland
in College Park Maryland he at demanded
that the students step aside from the on
the sidewalk the student did not step
aside the student was stabbed to death
in Portland Oregon two men had come to
the rescue of a young teenaged girl
wearing a hijab on the on the light rail
in Portland they were stabbed to death
then of course came Charlottesville and
the world saw the alt-right jump from
the Internet to the flesh with their
chance of Jews will not replace us there
tiki torches there melees and ultimately
the death of a counter protester Heather
hire run down by a bigot in a Dodge
Charger so yes I am scared and what is
to be done I will confess that my book
is pretty hard on Jews mostly mainline
Jewish organizations though
in the big glass edifices in New York
and Washington
I know amazing work is being done at the
synagogue level at the congregation
level but I don't think enough is being
done right now to counter the rising
tide of white nationalism and not just
in the United States all over in Hungary
in Poland white nationalists just won a
plurality of the parliament in Italy Oh
[ __ ] the the president of Hungary is
about to get overwhelmingly reelected
after running a campaign really against
George Soros who was obviously not
actually on the ballot Elly was now
called American Jewry the Jews of
silence for our acquiescence to the
oppression of Soviet Jewry
we were pretty feckless in our response
to the Holocaust to be honest - during
the rise of Hitler the American Jewish
Committee representing the more affluent
assimilated German Jews were promoting a
kind of quiet advocacy and diplomacy to
counter Nazism the American Jewish
Congress which was a readout of more
recent arrivals from Eastern Europe they
wanted a Brasher approach rallies
demonstrations direct appeals to the
Roosevelt administration the rabbi's
preached widely there were rallies but
really too many American Jews silence
was really the response why attract
attention of the anti-semites when
people like Charles Lindbergh and Henry
Ford people have such renown were
actually espousing pro-nazi views why
rock the boat and risk the same fate as
European Jewry like so many moments in
American and world history American
Jewry when facing this existential
threat just really couldn't quite get it
together as I said there is a really
amazing work and since my book has come
out I've gotten a lot of pushback I
expected the American Jewish Committee
and the Jewish Federations to defend
themselves and I accept that and what I
haven't expected is a lot of smaller
Jewish organizations and synagogues have
really come down hard on me and said
what about us we're doing wonderful
things I'm not saying they aren't but I
would say that if if the American Jewish
community in it's been all its strength
were really coming out against the rise
of bigotry in this country and abroad we
would know it I don't feel like we are
seeing that for decades now American
Jews have argued and argued but we've
argued over Israel we have our liberal J
Street and are more mainline
conservative AIPAC we have the new
Israel fund we have the American Jewish
Committee and what do they fight over
they fight over Israel for 25 years a
guy named Ken Stern told me he worked
for the American Jewish Committee he
finished his tenure as the director of
the division of anti-semitism and
extremism and when here when he arrived
at the AJC he told me the committee had
an entire floor devoted to domestic
issues like education immigration
inter-ethnic relations inter-religious
outreach but over time those concerns
were subordinated to the singular focus
on Israel clean energy okay but make
sure it relates to Israeli energy
security interfaith efforts fine as long
as they're geared to heading off the
boycott divestment sanctions movement
against Israel outreach to Hispanic
communities absolutely there are rising
force in American politics we need to
protect Israel the American Jewish
Committee saw where the big money was
why chase after $5,000 or $10,000
donations when hedge fund managers were
cutting checks of six figures or seven
figures but to get the big money the
committee needed to be more tempered
more conservative and more focused on
Israel it was the easiest way to focus
the Jew American Jewish attention Israel
was born of one of the worst atrocities
in human history certainly the worst
atrocity in Jewish history the Holocaust
its existence is a testament to the
desire to keep Jews safe but let me tell
you if the United States is a hostile
country to the Jew
Israel is not safe it is by far the
largest recipient of American military
aid Israel's Iron Dome missile shield
was built with Israeli ingenuity but
also a lot of American help Israeli
engineers actually helped design the
Joint Strike Fighter and Israel's Air
Force will be the only one in the Middle
East that gets the plane but when it
rolls off that assembly line it will be
rolling off in Fort Worth Texas not in
Tel Aviv the fact is that the Jewish
Haven is only safe as long as it's under
the American security umbrella American
Jewry should be at least as focused on
keeping the United States support safe
for Jews as it is for sustaining Israel
security at the height of the 2016
campaign when the alt-right dog
whistling was all over the place David
Harris the head of the American Jewish
Committee wrote a column for USA Today
happily recounting how Ivanka Trump had
converted to Judaism and how Chelsea
Clinton had married Marc Mezvinsky oh
joy he exulted whoever wins will bring a
Jewish family to the White House this is
exactly what he wrote he said how
American Jewish voters will respond to
Donald Trump's Jewish links and
pro-israel statements and to persistent
questions about the support he is
receiving from the far-right including
white supremacists and anti-semitic
groups remains to be seen but if past is
prologue there are likely to be some
Jews being both loudly supporting and
energetically opposing his candidacy
welcome to American presidential
politics and the Jews in 2016 I I have
to read this one sentence again he said
how American Jewish voters will respond
to Donald Trump's Jewish links and
pro-israel statements and to persistent
questions about the support he is
receiving from far-right including white
supremacists and anti-semitic groups
remains to be seen as if a presidential
candidate backed by white supremacists
an anti-semite
is normal I mean come on we can do
better than that as I was writing this
book I had lunch with a rabbi in
Washington named Daniel Zemel being
Jewish we took three hours for this
lunch and he's featured in the book a
lot he told me that after Trump was
elected president the Shabbat services
at Temple Micah that Friday night were
packed congregants were shell-shocked
they were looking for support and they
were looking for answers the scene
repeated itself the weekend of of
Trump's inauguration but six miles away
from rabbi cemil's synagogue on the
evening of december 14 2016 the
conference of Presidents of major
American Jewish organizations gathered
for a Hanukkah party co-hosted by the
Embassy of Azerbaijan at the Trump
International Hotel it is not a secret
that azerbaijan's record on human rights
abuses is atrocious
but azerbaijan has relations with israel
are warm Mort Klein the head of the
Zionist Organization of America blasted
what he called far left extremists who
were objecting to the site of the Jewish
umbrella group partying in the Lincoln
library of the Trump Hotel with
diplomats from Azerbaijan he said it
would have been terribly unwise for the
conference to have pulled out and say we
don't want to have this in the Trump
Hotel if the Trump held the Trump people
became aware of this they would have
been offended offended this was just
weeks after the Trump campaign had aired
its final ad on television that
inveighed against quote global special
interests as the Jewish faces of Lloyd
Blankfein from Goldman Sachs and Janet
Yellen from the Fed were going across
the screen I mean forget about dog
whistles this was like a foghorn
or as rabbis mo put it let's face it the
American Jewish community has been
abandoned by its leaders I want to be
clear here about one thing I am NOT
saying that the Jewish response the rise
of anti-semitism and white nationalism
should be uniform adoption of left-wing
politics some of the most articulate and
passionate denunciations of our drift
toward an intolerant authoritarianism
have come from conservatives
conservative Republicans and especially
conservative Republican Jews the defense
of American institutions those lefty
concepts as the Constitution or the rule
of law or law enforcement are American
intelligence these are these should not
be considered democratic or republican
endeavors these are American there are
certain lines that neither party is
supposed to cross bigotry racism
authoritarianism that's not liberal or
conservative that is American in closing
bear with me I want to share an obscure
story that has real meaning to me back
in 2014 before really anyone had heard
of the alt-right the vicious lads in
their parents basements who played who
play video games and we're hanging out
on the on these fever swamps of places
like 4chan and 8chan and reddit these
are online chat groups that you probably
don't even know exist they collectively
decided that a small group of women
video game writers had to be destroyed
their offense was that they were writing
video games for women they had video
games like for depression they had a
video game that didn't you know run
prostitutes over for points or shoot
down basically anybody so they attacked
and they used all these tricks that the
alt-right would eventually adopt they
doxed that means they published personal
information addresses phone numbers
social security numbers online so
anybody could go attack these women in
person or attack their bank accounts or
steal their identities they also did
this thing called swatting which is
where they would call the local police
station near there with the women's
houses and say hey I see there's a man
with a gun in this house and send the
SWAT team over to rain it's a terrible
thing even if the people are ok often
dogs get shot in the case of zoe quinn a
bitter ex-boyfriend had joined this
whole thing
and he compiled a mix of innuendo
sexually explicit Kissin tell stories
exaggerations and falsehoods into
something he called the Zoe Post and
then he put it online on 4chan and he
knew the loudest denizens that were
involved in what's called gamergate
would attack and they did the horrors
that were visited on Zoe Kent Quinn
bottled mine her Wikipedia site was
altered to read died October 14th 2014
that happened to be the next date of her
the date of her next public appearance
social media post urged her to kill
herself picture covered and semen and
the threat I mean if she's dead I things
like if I ever see you are doing a panel
at an event I am going to I will
literally kill you
or we have to rape Zoe Quinn and take
everything from her we have to ruin her
life remember all this woman did was
design video games so what happened to
Zoe Quinn was horrific but it was also
important because at that point most of
the racists and the anti-semites were
living in their own little worlds they
had Stormfront and the daily stormer and
these Klan websites and they were just
talking to each other but when they saw
what the misogynist lads could do to
these women they said aha it was like a
signal flare they realized wow we can do
this too we can spread our hate but we
need to leave our little cloistered
world and we need to go on to sites like
4chan and 8chan even the discussion
rooms of of YouTube and eventually
Twitter and by doing that they made sure
that a whole new generation would just
stumble into it you know the shooter in
the the shooter in parkland was come
swimming in this cesspool people are
just running into it and they're
learning about these new ideologies out
there because it's now much much more
easy to spread much easier to get the
word out but I bring this also up for a
more uplifting point Zoe Quinn is an
amazing woman
with her boyfriend happens to be a
yeshiva guy named Alex Lifshitz they
started an outfit called crash override
it was a support service for victims of
abuse online for social workers for
lawyers for cybersecurity experts and
the crash override website offers these
practical tools on how to combat this
kind of abuse it wasn't particularly
about anti-semitism was just abuse
although anti-semitism was always part
of it
in its first year crash override had a
hotline in 2015
zoe quinn personally handled more than
thousand calls she eventually had to
shut it down because she personally
couldn't do it all herself
it was just killing her so what would it
mean to Zoe are countless victims out
there if if Jewish wherewithal if Jewish
money and might and organizational
skills were put behind crash something
like crash override we actually did
practical things to combat what's
happening online in a society where
intolerance and hatred and just plain
nastiness are suddenly far more
tolerated anti-semitism is just one of
many horrors one of many that include
Islamophobia attacks on immigrants
racism but we're all in this together
anti-semitic hate crimes rose 57% in
2017 over 2016 that's the largest single
year it's single year jump in record and
that came after another big jump in 2016
during the campaign anti-semitic
thoughts have risen rose 34 percent in
2016 but that was more than matched by
the attacks on American Muslims which
was 57 percent and where Jews reporting
our reporting taunts and disruptions as
desecration of headstones spray paints
whatever Muslim Americans are actually
being killed and there was a girl who
was beaten to death outside of
Washington in 1958 when a synagogue in
Atlanta my synagogue the temple was
bombed by Klansmen
Ralph McGill was the editor of the
Atlanta Constitution put it succinctly
he said you do not preach and encourage
hate for the negro and hope to restrict
it to that field it is an old old story
when the Wolves of hate are loosed on
one people then no one is safe the
Wolves of hate have been loosed it's
time we refocus our gaze homeward to
unite around what it means to be
Americans and defend democratic
pluralism the world is watching so
I'm happy to take any and all questions
thank you thank you what are some
specific things you're speaking of
combating anti-semitism what specific
things can be done I I feel like I mean
specific specifically as I as I said I
think there are there are systems to
come back to work with the FBI and to
work but actually I was James Comey was
speaking to the anti-defamation league
about some of this and he was talking he
was talking about efforts to unite
Jewish organizations with the FBI to
start reporting and going after online
hate and trying to shut down some of the
websites he may not have gotten very far
because he was fired two days later but
it was an important moment and I think
the anti-defamation league is doing is
doing a lot of work and you know the
anti-defamation league I just I bring
them up because obviously you know
there's some controversy about the new
leadership of the ADL Abe Foxman was
always a very diplomatic man he was very
careful he did not want to be seen as a
liberal or a conservative the new leader
Jonathan Greenblatt has been more out
front and he's been criticized by some
Jewish Republicans because they think
that by being outspoken against
anti-semitism and and bigotry on the
right somehow he is speaking out against
Donald Trump I don't think that that's
correct but I think that the
anti-defamation league supporter
deserves our support
you know when the a the anti-defamation
league actually put together a what he
called a guide to the alt-right
alt-right and it went through a list of
some of the characters that are out
there leading these movements and some
of the characters in anything that they
listed are pretty prominent supporters
of Trump and it
and some Jewish Republican politicians
came out against the anti-defamation
league and said they were standing with
Mike Serna vich or this other guy I mean
I was it was shocking and I and I
thought wow and I didn't hear the
American Jewish Committee or the
American Jewish Congress or the New York
Jewish Federation stand up and say we
stand actually with the anti-defamation
league I didn't hear anything and I
think that standing for our institutions
and moving them to a more aggressive
position is is really important for the
American Jewish community
I think she's controlling hi I just
wonder where is Jared Kushner does he
know what's going on you know
I question was where is Jared Kushner um
you know Jared the the the fact that
Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump were
going to be in this White House we're
going it was kind of my talisman for you
know for anyone who thought it's
everything's fine everything's fine but
I mean ultimately you know if some if
some people are of are reluctant to
speak up certainly members of the Trump
family have been reluctant to speak up
and remember during the campaign Melania
Trump was asked about these attacks on
Julia Yaffe and she said well she
provoked it and Donald Trump was asked
in an interview with Wolf Blitzer about
the the the swarming all right and the
anti-semitism and the racism coming from
his supporters and he said I don't
control my supporters there has and I'm
not I don't pretend to know what's in
Donald Trump's mind I'm not calling him
an anti-semite I don't I don't but I
will say that I mean we have not exactly
seen forthright opposition to the swirl
of bigotry that has that has kind of
come in the wake of this campaign you
know there's a study that I excite in my
book about this these this group of
economists actually writing in a
peer-reviewed journal talked about a
group of taking a group of people and
before the election and showing them
saying that we are going to contribute
we if you if you want we can contribute
anonymously to this anti-immigration
group and most of the group's most of
the people that were being studied said
I don't I don't want you to do that even
anonymously I don't want you to do that
and then they studied over time during
the course of the election as more and
more people said yeah yeah you know just
do it quietly and then after the
election the same group of people came
back and and like 70 percent of them
wanted contributions to this group I
mean and I'm not saying that
anti-immigration is necessarily alright
bigotry is not the same but I will say
that you know then the mores of the
mores of a polite society are dropping
and I think that and I think that that's
what we are seeing around us okay sorry
I didn't mean to other person I thought
it was recognized I just want to comment
on a few of your comments that I think
are grossly inaccurate first of all you
focus on alt-right anti-semitism and I
share that anti-semitic knowledge at all
extreme left anti-semitism or Nation of
Islam auntie Semitism that exists as
well so a more balanced approach would
have been important secondly you fail to
recognize that the American Jewish
Committee formed the Muslim Jewish
Coalition for the express purpose of
fighting anti-semitism hatred and the
lack of pluralism similar things
associated with Latino coalition where
we form that as well and lastly it would
have been helpful if just talking about
one former employee of the AJC
you had met with
David Harris or members of the staff to
find out what we're doing on a global
basis to fight anti-semitism not only
the United States and in Europe as well
so I invite you to come to lunch one day
and have some facts so when your book
tour
you represent things as they are not as
you've selectively portrayed by the
input of one person okay I will I will
actually am meeting with leaders of the
of the Federation's in the and and some
AJC leaders in California in a couple of
weeks and I will say a repeat
I will repeat if the American Jewish
Committee and the mainline Jewish
organizations were forthrightly standing
up I would I think that we would see it
and we are not we are not so I will say
you and I can disagree on this and I I
get it
now I do want to address address the
Nation of Islam and anti-semitism of
what an anti-semitism of the of the left
and I always expected to talk about this
in fact I discuss it in my book at
length I didn't discuss it in this talk
but I will discuss it right now the
Nation of Islam I mean the the gutter
hatred and bigotry that Louis Farrakhan
has expressed is you know as as as
hateful and as bigoted and anti-semitic
as anything we've ever seen out of the
alt-right there's no question and I
condemn Louis Farrakhan and the Nation
of Islam's version of anti-semitism I
will also say this Louis Farrakhan in
1995 organized the Million Man March
about I think it's about half million
áback men came to came to the Million
Man March that was pretty much the
pinnacle of the of Louis Farrakhan's
power the Nation of Islam is a small
organization it is present in urban
centers around the country but is not a
swelling movement in fact Louis
Farrakhan cannot put a hundred thousand
fascists on the streets of Budapest
Louis Farrakhan cannot pass a measure
through the Parliament a poll
saying it is illegal to say that poles
had anything to do with the Holocaust
Louis Farrakhan has not grabbed a
plurality of the Italian parliament and
Louis para ver con did not but could
make the final runoff for the presidency
of France so I would say that we have to
focus on where the movement is where the
threat is and I do not believe that
Louis Farrakhan and his brand of hatred
is a rising threat the way white
nationalism is white nationalism is a
riving rising threat throughout the West
it is these are not equal now I will
also talk about the anti-semitism of the
left through the through and
anti-zionism in the BDS movement now I
will tell you what's happening in France
and then Britain is really frightening
it's very I mean if you're French and
you are seeing and you are seeing you
know anti anti-israeli sentiment rise up
to the point where where people are
chanting in the street death of the Jews
and a Holocaust survivor could be
murdered in her flat and at the same
time marine lepen
is is mobilizing an entire movement from
the right you have it coming from the
right and you ever coming from the left
that is horrifying I will also talk
about the BDS movement in the United
States obviously there are Jews and I
know them who are on campuses right now
who feel uncomfortable with it with the
sentiment the anti-israeli sentiment on
in liberal organizations on campuses I
will also tell you I have a I have a
stepdaughter she's at Barnard just up
the street
she is bat Mitzvahed she is incredibly
Jewish identified she loves being Jewish
she also hates Israel now I will tell
you if you want to argue with her on
policy if you want to make the case that
she her position is on Israel is wrong
and you were going to argue why it's
wrong
you should but if you're gonna call her
an anti-semite you will get nowhere
because she is not an anti-semite she is
somebody who really does not like Israel
and I don't I sit and argue with her
about this a lot but I am not so silly
as to call my own stepdaughter an
anti-semite who loves being Jewish so I
do know I draw a great distinction
between the BDS movement you know I
talked to him at the beginning of that
thing I talked about I talked about the
argument that I had with a rabbi at
Hillel over the two-state solution
versus the Canton solution and I
remember when I was a senior in college
I wrote this was in 1988 I wrote a
column that said if the if Israel cannot
deal cannot actually forthrightly settle
the palestinian crisis then someday
we're going to lose a generation of jews
to a we're going to rise up with the
occupation as what they think of as
israel and nothing was done and now we
have and that's scary and i think that
that is something to be addressed but is
not to be addressed in a discussion
about anti-semitism do you think that
social media has created more any
semitism or do you think that social
media is just reflecting the existing
anti-semitism in america thank you
that's a great question and I think
obviously I think I think social media
exposed anti-semitism that is ancient
and long for long standing in corners of
the American culture but I will also say
that is created an avenue to spread this
form of bigotry and also just conspiracy
theories now there was this there's this
guy his name is PewDiePie
I won't i won't spell you his name
pewdiepie but he's like this youtuber is
from sweden my kids you know i teenage
girls used to love him they've kind of
outgrown him but
PewDiePie did this thing where he he
hired these guys from India for five
bucks to do something and he wouldn't
say what it was and then they said it
was to see if what the bullet the guys
from India would do and what he did was
he he was shocked because they actually
did it they unfurled a banner somewhere
and then it was somewhere in India that
said death to the Jews and danced around
with it and everyone like all these kids
saw this and beauty pie was like
pretended to be aghast and embarrassed
that this actually happened but the fact
that he even thought to do that and the
fact that kids you know eleven-year-old
boys who love PewDiePie saw these Indian
Indian boys in a jungle dancing around
with a sign that said death for the Jews
that's scary to me because you know it
used to be hard her to get your word
across now it's really easy it's really
easy to get your message out and kids
are swimming in this cesspool online
that it's almost hard to avoid at this
point thank you for a very interesting
discussion I'm glad you got to the ADL I
was going to ask you about that because
you didn't mention it in your in your
talk but they were throwing up in a
question but what is in Donald Trump's
mind is the $64,000 question and I would
I would say that the attitude of most
citizens of the State of Israel and of
course Netanyahu in sharp comparison to
Barack Obama's lack of popularity in
Israel largely answers that question I
would agree that a more forceful
denunciation of the faithful side of
some of Donald Trump's supporters
and he you said he he made the comment
well I can't I can't control the the
attitude of the supporters is there any
evidence at all that he in any way has
supported anti-semitism in any form
well look there's actually a lot of
stories around about his childhood and
about his father I've heard these things
we've never at the New York Times we've
never been able we've been written about
them because we've actually tried very
hard to find out you know for the
validity of them and it's hard to of
course we have written about you know
the history of you know redlining blacks
out of out of Trump Organization
buildings and things like that but I
will say that there are weird things
that happen in this White House now
Trump will like retweet a meme of you
know that the rumor that that tweet of
the guy who is wrestling
yet it was Trump wrestling a CNN guide
to the ground and smashing his head well
it only took about you know a few clicks
to find that that same person who put
together that image had put together the
most noxious racist anti-semitic images
also now I spend time on social media I
would not have run across that how did
Donald Trump find that guy I mean he's
actually done it many times it and
there's there was during the campaign
quite a few times
he was trucking in imagery that was just
kind of one step removed from blatant
racism and blatant anti-semitism and it
was one step removed but it would it
it's these were images that that
wouldn't have been easy to find unless
you were somehow swimming around in the
4chan eight chance s pool it's a
question that I've always wanted to know
and you know we've we've got the New
York Times we've actually tried to
figure out there's guy Brad parts cow
who runs his social media operation he's
going to actually
was just named his campaign manager for
2020
I'm sure Brad prosecute must know how in
the world these images crop up in in in
the messages coming out of the White
House but we don't we don't know and I
don't want to you know make inferences
here Mike
during the Charlottesville protests one
of the chance was Jews will not replace
us and Trump said that these were good
good people to me that's anti-semitic
during the campaign there was a picture
of Hillary Clinton superimposed on a
six-pointed Jewish star taken from an
anti-semitic website and that was used
in one of trumps ads so if he and then
when they interviewed some people in
Charlottesville a lot of the men were
very angry that Trump's daughter married
a Jew so if that's anti-semitism has
gone up 57 percent since Trump has been
president and he was not elected he was
a he was not elected president he was
appointed by the electoral college which
was not elected so if that isn't
anti-semitism what a dog whistles what
is he's an anti-semite plain and simple
even though his daughter is married to a
Jew that I was event in that image of of
the Jewish star with Hillary Clinton is
one of them one of the main examples
that I say of that they are somehow that
somehow that campaign was swimming in
some very filthy waters and I would
agree with that and and what happened in
Charlottesville what I hope was a
wake-up call for everyone because you
know Jews will not replace us is a it
originally was you will not replace us
but in the all right world in the white
nationalist world white nationalist
believe that
there is something called white genocide
going on and in the white genocide there
are african-americans and Latino
Americans and Muslim Americans and
they're all taking over for the white
people but it's hard for them that why
the white nationalists to understand
this because they believe that
african-americans and Latinos and
Muslims are inferior creatures to them
so how could it be that they are being
supplanted they're being beaten by these
inferior creatures and the answer is
Jews because in their great in their
great Pantheon they have decided that
the Jews are the puppet masters running
all of this I don't want to appear naive
and I don't well with the emergence of
so with the emergence of so many Muslim
people I don't want that to appear
prejudiced but they have infiltrated
into the majority of the populations of
many countries and I have always felt
that perhaps the emergence of hearing so
much hate if it's coming from the
Muslims in terms of Israel or in terms
of anything has caused a lot of
anti-semitism does that make me sound
terrible I don't mean to say the Muslims
aren't good people but I feel the
emergence of their group in such large
numbers has created this hatred okay so
the question is this is true as I as I
said earlier I draw a distinction
between white nationalist anti-semitism
and the anti-semitism that is emerging
out of the left in Europe which is born
of anti-zionism and what you were seeing
in France is these pincers where you
have white nationalists you have a
nationalist movement in the National
Front coming at Jews from the right
you have a lot of Islamic in immigrants
or second-generation Muslims in in
France coming at Jews from the left and
it is creating a horrific situation
there's no question about it I do not
see that happening in the United States
I don't I mean on campuses I see that I
see an a certainly an anti and
anti-israel sentiment an anti Zionist
sentiment but I don't feel like Muslims
have that much power but they do I think
that they that that Islamic Muslim
months of Muslim immigrants in Europe
are certainly exerting pressure on their
societies to oppose Israel and that is a
way has had this odd metastases into
anti-semitism where basically if you
were a Jew in France or you're a Jew in
Britain you're made to answer for Israel
and you know we shouldn't be made to
answer for for the policies of another
nation we are are for Israel I mean for
Israel
it's abroad it's like it's it's like you
you must renounce Israel or you all be
attacked as some kind of racist and that
is a sentiment that we are seeing more
and more it's very scary you talk about
Jewish organizations coming together
trying to deal more at the subject of
the anti-semitism that's arising but I
wonder if we ever get the Orthodox and
any significant numbers to join us I get
the impression I live in an area in
Brooklyn
that's rather Orthodox and they voted in
large numbers for Trump and even a few
times I brought up somewhere about
Charlottesville I got a very muted
response I get the feeling that because
Trump president Trump moved the embassy
to to tell it to to Jerusalem they like
overlooked want to overlook this the
other aspect that with Charlottesville
I get that feelin that and even in my
own family I have a nephew who wasn't
raised that way became Orthodox I tried
to bring up the subject with him he shut
me up
he said Uncle Peter I don't deal with
those those issues it's like he didn't
want to know I I actually talked about
this in my book
a lot in fact I opened my book with this
the notion that there are this
development of the of the tribalist Jews
versus the internationalist Jews and the
internationalist Jews feel like the
Jewish community thrives at a time when
walls come down when borders are blurred
when we are less nationalist but the
tribalist Jews actually thrive in a kind
of an era of nationalism and there are a
lot not all but there are a lot of
Orthodox Jews who are you know tribalist
identified they everything comes down to
Israel for them because no fortress
Israel that is it so they are willing I
mean you know the desire to move that
embassy was like it literally they had a
consulate in Jerusalem and an embassy in
Tel Aviv and they're moving the sign
from like the consulate to the embassy
and now as an embassy but that had such
incredible meaning to so many Jews and I
would call those the tribalist Jews and
right now the tribalists and the
internationalists are really at odds and
that that focal point is coming into the
Trump administration I guess partially I
wanted to speak about that what do you
say to the Trump supporter who is Jewish
and who's voting and who supports Trump
blindly as far as I'm concerned because
they feel he it feels that Trump is
going to be better for Israel
I mean without looking at what he's
doing here all they care about is that
he's better
for Israel I mean well how do you answer
that how do you what do you say to them
well I mean I'm not here to like speak
I'm not here to oppose Donald Trump but
I am here to say that I do believe as I
said in this been my talk I do believe
that Israel ultimately is only as safe
as the United States is safe for the
Jews I mean if the United States turns
to be a hostile power to Jews how much
longer do you think that we are going to
be you know sending five billion dollars
of military aid a year how much longer
do you think the United States is going
to be the constant partner to Israel if
this if anti-semitism Wells up here I
mean you're already seeing it in Europe
no the British government is under
pressure to cut ties with Israel because
of a because of the this cent rising
sentiment of anti anti Zionism and
anti-semitism that will happen here too
and I would just say you know we have
ultimately a responsibility to keep the
United States a democratic pluralist
society and well we are certain we don't
you know I talked about this in the book
too
I mean we were for the longest time it
felt like the United States was
inexorably slowly progressing toward a
more inclusive pluralist democratic
society and it kind of reached its
apotheosis in 2008 in 2008 we were in
the middle of a you know an unbelievable
financial collapse and it was a time
people were hundreds of thousands of
people were losing you know losing jobs
every month it was a time when you could
have seen this uprising of hatred and
suspicion and we elected our first black
president and everyone said wow we're
really we really are a country that is
inexorably moving toward in toward
acceptance and inclusiveness and you
know what right now we aren't so the
question is are we in a in is this
moment to aberration and we'll move back
toward that
toward that progression toward
acceptance or are we gonna look back and
think actually those years between 1960
and 2008 were actually the aberration
and I think that's why this this moment
in American history is so important do
you feel that it's particularly
challenging to fight alright nationalism
given the Rives for some time of some
ultra-right groups in israel that while
they are a minority have a significant
influence on Israeli policies does it
become difficult because Israel becomes
associated to some degree with with
those those parties we know that's true
on the left but is it also more
difficult to fight it on the right i I
think that it is incumbent on American
Jews to teach the next that the the
rising generation of young Jews to
identify with Judaism as a religion and
not as a nation and I think that this is
one of the problems with I think the
American Jewish community is that it has
become so self identified with Israel
that we get into these conundrums why
should it matter that there is a heart
you know strain of nationalism in
bigotry in Israel to move to me I don't
think it should but the reason is is
because we are become because American
Jews have become so inextricably linked
to Israel that we are made that we are
answerable to political trends no 8,000
miles away or 3,000 or whatever it is
and I think that that's a problem for us
because I think as I said I think that
it's time for the American Jewish
community to really stand up for
American values and if that means you
know a little less emphasis on Israel
and Israeli politics all the better
I'm a I'm a Holocaust survivor I've been
very involved I'm a Holocaust survivor
for many years I've been involved with a
museum in Washington
their logo is never again and every time
I go to their meetings and I'm in
Washington next week and I hear never
again in my lifetime for 70 years it is
ever again and it's happening and I as a
child who went through the I'm from
Hungary from Budapest I went through the
birth and rise of Mussolini and of
Hitler who started out appealing to the
young people and making the place better
there's such a parallel and I mentioned
this to several friends and they all
kind of said agree it's exactly what's
happening now with mr. Trump as
president you know 57 is really really
scary you know two weeks before the
election I was I was I was giving us a
talk to a group of elderly LD elderly
Marylanders just outside of Washington
and I was saying I was talking about my
experiences with the alt-right
and I was saying you know in two weeks
Hillary Clinton is going to be elected
president and we're gonna look back and
we're gonna wonder if what we saw during
this campaign was the last gasp of a
dying movement or is it or was it you
know the the birth of a kind of
irredentist white nationalism and then I
was wrong but I remember after the
speech another Holocaust survivor pulled
me aside and said I wouldn't be so kind
so confident about the outcome of this
election and I would not be so confident
that this is going to be something that
fades away because I've seen it too
there is something about nationalism
that really brings out the worst in
people
and we are in a nationalist age right
now
know when there's a a reporter a
reporter for The Times David Sanger was
interviewing Trump during the election
and Trump was trying to describe his
foreign policy and David Sanger said
well is it do you would you call it an
America first policy and he said yes yes
I would call it an America first policy
and then he started using this all the
time and I think at first he didn't
understand the resonance about America
first game he didn't understand that
that was Lindbergh's party he didn't
understand that it was associated with
Nazi sympathies but then at some point
somebody must have told him right but he
keeps using it there is a power to
nationalism that unleashes you know ill
wind and we are we are in the middle of
an ill wind right now we have time for
one more question but before we take it
I wanted everyone to know that the
sanctuary is open after the book sign if
anybody would like to see her a
beautiful sanctuary
who's got the last question right here
yes so I think it would be very helpful
to focus on what needs to be done and
what we can do and one thing that needs
to be done is we need to flood the
internet with messages of tolerance and
equality another thing we need to do is
flood university campuses with the same
message now I don't personally know how
to do these things but I'd like some
help and we need to get the message out
and it doesn't matter whether it comes
from this American Jewish organization
or that one that I always give $36 to
but but how do we how do we organize
let's organize like the students in
parkland
and let's do it you know I a synagogue
at the city at the synagogue level
amazing things are happening I talked
about I in the book I talk about this
organization in in Nashville called Noah
that is competitors linked
two mosques a no font like three
synagogues and a bunch of different
churches white black together into this
umbrella organization that is doing
wonderful inter inter religious work and
I think you see it there's there's
organizations all over the country in in
small scales but they really are giving
people an option and there are you know
new organizations Jewish organizations
like bend the arc and Jewish Council for
Public Affairs is trying to get trying
to get more - more more public about
these things I think that there is an
effort and it's kind of up to us to
encourage it and to join but because I
think if you look you will find avenues
for that okay so I think we want to
thank Jonathan and join us in the
hallway we'll get him to sign your books
but please don't attack him with your
questions there get let him sign the
books